what do you have for breakfast for
breakfast I had the same thing I eat
every day which was a wonderful egg
omelette including chopped up jalapeno
peppers onions mushrooms and spinach
sounds delicious optimal at this
altitude I can run flat out for a half
mile before my hands start shaking so
now suppose I'm a cybernetic organism
living fish yoga medical facility this
episode is brought to you by headspace
the world's most popular meditation app
I have it on my phone I use it all the
time when I'm in ubers when I'm in
airplanes when I'm in those in-between
spaces and I want to do some good for
myself across all of the guests that
I've had on this podcast more than
eighty percent have the common behavior
of the common habit of some type of
meditative practice it does not have to
be complicated or expensive headspace is
meditation made simple I've used it for
hundreds of sessions myself it provides
guided meditations that you can use
whenever you want wherever you want
whether on your phone computer or tablet
they have sessions that focus on
everything from decreasing stress and
anxiety to eating healthier sleeping
better and even being more creative but
I suggest you keep it simple simple
simple this is that huge impact in my
life try there take ten program it is
fantastic
ten minutes of guided meditation today
for ten days it costs you nothing try it
out and I promise and I don't do this
very much that you will see a
significant benefit from it download the
headspace app and train your mind for a
happier healthier life learn more head
space.com forward slash Tim that's
headspace calm forward slash Tim
this podcast is brought to you by 4
Sigma tech I reached out to these
Finnish folks young entrepreneurs very
talented
after a Acrobat introduced me to one of
their products which is mushroom coffee
this specific one includes chaga
and lion's mane and knocked my socks off
I highly recommend if you try it you
start with half a packet it's very
strong and lights you up like a
Christmas tree in the best way possible
people are always asking me what I use
for cognitive enhancement and for right
now this is the answer I try to force
this on all of my houseguests it is a
hell of a thing if I have employees or
people come over who are working on
projects with me I always try to feed it
to them because I'm going to get the
limitless effect it gets a lot more out
of them the first time I mentioned this
product and for sig Matic on the podcast
their products sold out in less than a
week so you may want to check them out
soon if you're listening to this and the
coffee tastes like coffee
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water and oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you would get in a
regular cup of coffee I don't get any
jitters acid reflux or any stomach burn
any of that it's very unusual and very
very cool so if you don't like caffeine
they also offer very strong but caffeine
free mushroom elixirs which I will
sometimes have in the evening I find
chaga specifically to be very very
grounding and earthy so that is another
option and I have a cupboard full of
their products at the moment which is
right around the corner in my kitchen
you can try something you can try a
sample pack which is great also right
now by going to four sig Matic calm
forward slash Tim that's for sig Matic
fo you are SI g ma TI c calm forward
slash tim and use the code tim TI m to
get 20% off of your first order and
they're not that expensive anyway if you
are in the experimental mindset I do not
think you'll be disappointed to try ma
[Music]
ladies and germs this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode of Tim
Ferriss show where it is my job to
interview world-class performers and
tease out the habits routines tactics
etc that you can use and apply in
immediate inmediatamente that's what he
says in this manual or si si habla
espanol okay so moving on why am I in
the language vibe because I've got a
Japanese treat for you guys this time
it's not military it's not entertainment
it's not chess it is not business per se
we have a master Japanese bladesmith and
it is a very fascinating story I have
since day one on this podcast wanted to
have the chance to a long in-depth
conversation with the bladesmith I love
knives I collect knives and now we have
Murray Carter on the podcast I'm not
going to give you his full bio because
it unfolds in the process of this
conversation but I had an absolute blast
if you want to get into knives you want
to get into Japan you want to get into
martial arts if you have even a passing
interest in someone with a high degree
of I'm not going to say OCD but
attention to detail that nearly boggles
the mind somebody went from class clown
to doing an 18 year stint in Japan then
this is the podcast for you I really am
so excited to provide this to you guys
because it exceeded all of my
expectations
Murray Carter he is at Carter cutlery on
Facebook and Instagram definitely check
out the Instagram was raised in Nova
Scotia in meth in Canada find neighbors
to the north and came in contact with
Japanese culture when he attended a
karate competition at the age of 15 and
I'm going to save a lot of his story for
the actual conversation which leads to a
chance encounter with a 16th generation
bladesmith then 18 years in Japan then
being declared an alien of extraordinary
ability those words are capitalized by
the I NS in the US when he was granted
immigration status to relocate is now in
Portland Oregon
this is for me a really really fun
podcast to finally publish it's one I
have dreamt of having since the very
first episode even before recording the
first episode of the Tim Ferriss show so
without further ado please enjoy
actually I'm going to have some ado but
whether I do please enjoy this
conversation with Marie Carter now and
also just as a quick reminder and
suggestion if you are not subscribed to
five bullet Friday this is one of the
most popular things that I do it is
completely free
every Friday send on a short email with
bullets of the coolest articles
purchases movies hacks experiments etc
that I have either been dabbling with or
enjoyed or had referred to me by all
these various experts I have in my life
and that I've spent time with so 500
Friday it's free it has a 60 Plus
percent open rate and it is a lot of fun
so if you haven't checked that out go to
Tim blog forward slash Friday and you
can sign up Tim that blog forward slash
Friday and there's all sorts of
exclusive stuff private QAS
events and so on things from various
guests it's fun so check that out 500
friday tim dot blog forward slash friday
and now more regarder marie welcome to
the show yeah thanks for having me on
Tim I am very excited to connect for
many reasons a number one from the very
outset one of my fantasies for this
podcast was at some point having on a
master bladesmith and what we can get
into why that's the case but I wanted
that to be one of my objectives and
fantasies realized in the sense so I'm
checking that box number one number two
is that I felt like you were somehow
brought to me not to get too woowoo but
just in the last few months I've had a
close friend who's former Special
Operations tell me that I had to take a
class of yours at the very least to make
a neck knife or or some other type of
knife to try to learn the craft and then
also spent time last week with a
well-known film
whose son has become a huge fan of yours
and is studying the craft so on many
levels I think that this was in some
form destined to be and I would love to
start with just a little bit of
background and I think that may be the
easiest way to jump into it is to say
cover where you grew up and how Japan
entered the picture
sure yeah I'd be happy to share that
story with you I grew up in Halifax Nova
Scotia Canada and at a very young age I
became very interested in martial arts
and military history and the kind of the
outdoors and watching movies like
Jeremiah Johnson and so on gave me a
great fascination for tools and knives
and weapons and so on and when I was 15
years old I was lucky to attend a
regional karate competition as a guest
not as an observer and that really
piqued my interest in so I actually
enrolled in a karate dojo and and did
that for several years and and that
started my real fascination with Japan
and then of course I kind of coupled
that that interest with reading books
about the martial arts and then jazz and
so on and of course you know samurais
and samurai swords and and the blades
that they they used and that's kind of
where the fascination with Japan started
when did that become and how did that
become an opportunity to go to Japan and
in terms of age you were what 15 or so
at the time well I started karate when I
was fifteen that would be in high school
and I graduated high school when I was
seventeen and then turned 18 that summer
and I worked for a full year well I
worked for I don't know several months
and then the spring of the following
year while I was still 18 I did travel
to Japan and the the destination within
Japan was kind of predetermined for me
that was the prefecture called Kumamoto
Prefecture on the island of Kyushu the
southernmost of the four main islands of
Japan because that's where the
karate dojo was located that I was going
to attend to further and continue my
studies in karate what type of what type
of karate was that it's a it's called
Chico you it's spelled CH I tio - are
y-you and it's a it's a version of she
told you which is a little bit more well
known I guess it originates from Okinawa
and one of the main features of Chi told
you was a higher more mobile stance than
a lot of the other traditional forms of
karate like Shotokan or Goju which are
very low very like God low center of
gravity stances for for kind of solidity
but lacking maybe a little bit in
mobility and flexibility so when I first
came across a few of the snippets of
your bio I thought to myself okay this
is really a conversation that has to
happen because one of the most
life-changing events in my life was 1992
I was in high school 15 and I had the
opportunity to switch out of Spanish
class because I'd concluded I was bad at
Spanish into a different language and my
friends were in Japanese class and I was
always fascinated by martial arts and
ninjas and so on and went to then
Japanese class six months later had the
opportunity to leave the US on my first
extended trip overseas to a sister
school which was in Tokyo so at 15 went
to Tokyo and stayed there for a year in
a Japanese school with a Japanese family
and I at that time just I'm going to die
not really digression because I feel
like I want to share this with you so
there's a little bit of common ground I
remember the first time I went to a
karate school in Japan to take a class
and I went to a saddle Chi cago I went
to a salic high school and that was my
first introduction to leg kicks and
mainly on the receiving end and
you know that you were the punching bag
I was a punching bag and I remember that
I came in and they're like oh you know
they're like oh this will take former or
at the time current wrestler foreigner I
was the only one in the school right
okay well like let's see let's see how
you move around and the no head contact
and some punching this guy in the chest
and every time I punched him in the
chest who kicked me in the leg and I
said well with that's a great trade I'm
just going to punch you in the chest all
day you can kick me in the leg as many
times as you want and I couldn't go to
school the next day better leg was all
swollen because my leg was ruined how
did how did you then go from I guess two
questions number one is how did the
opportunity come about for you to travel
to Japan
to further your studies and then
secondly where did where did blades come
into play so you know when I was in high
school I really caught a travel bug and
that kind of fed into my fears kind of
independent spirit and although it
wasn't really popular at the time I
started hitchhiking when I was 14 years
old and I and I found the wondrous joys
of being able to hike out to a highway
and stick my thumb out and get to places
I wanted to get to without having had to
save up money to buy my own car pay for
the insurance or pay for the gasoline it
was a wonderful experience and I
traveled all over the province of Nova
Scotia doing that and you know the more
I did it it kind of the more obsessed
and compelled I felt to do that so by
the time I was 16 years old I actually
traveled to Europe by myself over the
school Christmas vacation and spent
three weeks in Europe visiting some
acquaintances and also you know
venturing to places I had never been by
myself before so after high school I was
very keen to travel and I although I had
this nagging feeling in the back of my
mind that you know studies were awaiting
and that there was a an expectation both
self-incurred and and and you know
through my family to attend higher
education
couldn't ignore the the overwhelming
desire to travel so after high school I
started to put this trip together that
really was supposed to be a
round-the-world tour when I was still in
high school one of the seniors that
graduated two years before me had done a
round-the-world tour at the time I
believed you could through some
different Airlines you could purchase a
very special plane ticket where so long
as you kept moving in the same direction
around the globe for one set fare was
something like six thousand dollars or
something at the time you could continue
to keep flying to different destinations
so long as you kept moving in one
direction so that eventually you would
end up in the same place that you
started from and then your ticket would
expire so whether it was around the
world airfare basically and I when this
senior came back from his world trip his
story was featured in the local
newspaper and I read it in its entirety
and became very inspired and thought wow
that's exactly what I want to do is
emulate this round-the-world tour and so
I concocted a plan that would have me
hitchhike across North America and then
from the west coast depart to Japan and
stay there for six months where I would
continue and further my education in
karate and hopefully have some sort of
cultural experience while I was there
but I didn't know what that was going to
look like and from there I was going to
travel around the rest of Southeast Asia
I had planned to take a cargo ship I
think from there to India and then
another cargo ship from India to Africa
and travels to Africa and up through
Europe and back to Nova Scotia my
hometown of that was the plan
and I had budgeted time for it had
budgeted money for it and you know I had
I was in the process of actively trying
to establish connections and links and
leads you know so that I would know
people at some of these destinations I
was hoping to get to but I probably had
30 or 40 percent of it figured out and
the rest I would
just going to wing you know wing it as I
went along it's a good ratio I think
that's actually very good ratio if I did
it well just like your friends in in
certain communities the high-speed
low-drag you know there's there's beauty
but not being you know chained down with
too many plans or promises so yeah well
as a friend of mine Rolf Potts who wrote
a book that had a huge impact on me
called vagabonding who is a long long
time long-term traveler ultimately the
ability to improvise is more valuable
than the a lot of the planning you do on
the front end which you put differently
and end so you get to Japan you have
that you have this 40% figured out what
happens yeah so as fate would have it so
I immediately enrolled in the karate
dojo what they call a homebrew dojo
which is like the headquarters for our
style of Chico yukata and I did I just
want to say I want to put a plug in
there that that they were very very kind
to me and it was a great experience and
I can't say enough kind things about
that about the people that I met there
and that the the sensei who was there
but I digress
I was very keen and every morning
started at 6 o'clock where we would meet
and go into a special tatami mat room
and light incense and kind of give
homage to the ancestors of the karate
sensei's family who you know kind of who
started the whole thing who had passed
on and then we would go to each corner
of the room each one of the participants
and sit in zazen or basically sit on
your knees you know with your feet kind
of tucked up underneath your buttocks
for 30 minutes and it was absolutely
excruciating and your feet would fall
asleep and you're wondering why in the
world you travelled across the globe to
find yourself sitting in this
excruciating position for 30 minutes
every morning but after that 6:30 the
bell would ring much to our relief and
then we would go off and we would meet
in the karate dojo at 6:45 and
we had practices every morning like that
and then we have practices three times I
think was Monday Wednesday Fridays in
the evening and you know I was just in
karate heaven and you know I was
practicing with with some guys who would
progress on to be world champion so I
really was amongst some great skill and
talent and dedicated folks but what
happened the the connection denies was
this roughly around the fourth week of
practicing karate it was one of those
evening practices and we were doing
let's see if I can recall what is called
a jumping flying sidekick
and so you would kind of run up you're
going to do the triple jump and launch
yourself into the air and do a sidekick
at some imaginary target no one ever
taught you that if you actually make
contact in that position what you would
do next but mostly it was just like
through the air I think we were very ill
prepared for actually kicking anything
in that manner and you certainly
wouldn't want to go running up and jump
at a wall and try to kick it because I
don't think the outcome would be very
favorable but anyway when I was coming
down to land from that position I didn't
quite have my feet knees in front of me
and so that so I pretty much had one of
my legs I think was my left leg I was
kicking with my right leg and my left
leg when I came down and landed I
dislocated my knee oh so so it was first
when he was kind of a mild dislocation
but it was a dislocation nonetheless and
I had to go to the hospital and get a
bunch of liquid removed from somewhere
in the knee joint and they and the
doctor there put a cast on my leg that
basically went from my left ankle all
the way up to my you know top of my
thigh my left leg and he said yeah I had
to keep it on for three weeks and and
you know that's the curse of being an
eighteen year old you think you're
invincible so of course I convinced them
to take it off I think after one week
and I never ever fully recovered in fact
it turns out I've got completely torn
ACL and I've been living with it and
managing just fine for all these years
ever say
it's almost 30 years later I'm 47 them
so so now I'm in mobile and I'm in the
karate dojo kind of in there in the the
barracks we'll we'll call it and not
really able to practice and the cut out
day teacher comes in she pulls say send
today was his name great net great man
and he kind of threw a Japanese language
textbook at me and I couldn't tell like
if it was an aggressive throw or a kind
toss but either way it really was an
amazing gift and up to that point I had
acquired no Japanese language ability
and here was a textbook that was a very
well-written textbook and I started to
read it and work through the problems
and started to study the language and
that changed everything
and what was what was the consequence of
adding some Japanese speaking ability to
your skill set at that point well I
think you're you're aware because I
could tell from the way you've spoken
some Japanese words that you've acquired
quite a level of proficiency in the
language but you know you'd opened up a
whole lot more doors to me and of course
it opened up conversation it opened up
friendships it opened up the
possibilities of travel pursuing hobbies
outside of karate I know I thought that
I had a very kind of open mind when I
went to Japan but in hindsight really I
was just I was just bonkers for karate
and I really wasn't seeing much outside
of that world but once I started to
learn the language and made some friends
who were outside of the the karate
circle that's when everything really
opened up for me and a lot of doors
opened and that's what opened up the
possibility to start studying
bladesmithing so I had a very similar
experience a different domain but not
too dissimilar I went to a school in
Tokyo called
a sake a cult or gakuen which is in
Kichijoji
so for those people in or eager to visit
say Tokyo the inokashira park is right
next to or very close to where this
schools located and as a student I had
to wear the uniform looks like a sort of
a Chinese like mandarin collar
odd-looking safeco as they call it and
I'm allowed to add your size oh yeah
they need to do some special some
special work to get a first-year high
school student to fit this jacket so it
was a I was actually very fond of having
a uniform it's simplified things
dramatically so I had this uniform and
as part of the school it was very much
Where's Waldo in the sense that I could
easily be spotted as the only American
in this school 5,000 Japanese and
everyone had to do boo cups asobu katsu
could is
after-school activities exactly you have
to choose a club it is mandatory or was
at least at say K so I had to choose
between well the clubs that were eager
or interested in potentially having me
were rug big so like all right you're
bigger than most first-year so that'll
be an asset
kendo which I was interested in already
and that's where I thought I was headed
and then judo approached me and judo I
thought at the time was very much like
say Aikido where it's some guy comes at
you with this very exaggerated foe knife
thrust and then you whip him around and
Steven Seagal him to the ground I was
like well it's not terribly interesting
to me because from all the wrestling and
so on that I've done I'm more interested
in a resisting opponent okay and then
said judo guys taught me or showed me
very quickly that judo is very much for
contact and really similar to wrestling
and when at the time I couldn't read a
single kanji so the Chinese care for
people who were listening Chinese
characters adopted by the Japanese had a
basic grasp of the syllabaries of
Japanese so the hitogata and katakana
but otherwise was really at a where is
the bathroom thank you good morning
level of Japanese and it was it wasn't
until I had the motivation to get better
at judo and realized that the best
textbooks were all in Japanese at the
time at least and then had friends
support me by pointing me to comic books
that I could use to learn dialogue that
all the doors opened up like you said
and I just want to speak in defense of
Japanese people for a second here which
is to say that a lot of non Japanese who
visit Japan come back and they're like
ah the inscrutable Japanese they're so
xenophobic and they're so hard to
connect with and I don't think that's I
don't think that's actually a fair
assessment in most cases the Japanese
this is a bit of a rant so bear with me
but the when they were when either the
the gods of the universe were handing
out phonemes and sounds the Japanese got
a pretty short hand they didn't get a
lot of sound so Japanese are very
insecure about their ability in other
line
and have trouble as most people know
distinguishing between LNR and so on and
there as a result to have a very rote
driven approach to memorizing say vocab
but they shy away from speaking or
trying to speak English and I think that
is at least in my experience the main
barrier as soon as you speak even you
can hold a two-minute conversation or
you have a dozen phrases memorized I
mean they will literally clap their
hands I mean you believe this and go oh
sure wow that's exactly like the the the
the response that you get is so
exaggerated ah but wonderful in Japan
that as soon as you make the effort like
all of the doors open and it's just and
so that's I'm going to shut up now but
the I just I hate to hear the Japanese
described as so arm's distance and so on
for people who have not taken the time
to learn even ten words in Japanese sure
but I said so I get very excited one and
I feel like there's someone who's had a
similar experience so how did the blades
then come into the picture well I just
just before I get into that I just
wanted to comment on your experience in
Japan and it's cool that we were in
Japan at the same time because I've been
there since 1988
so in 92 you know I was I was up up to
my eyeballs in bladesmithing and all
sorts of other things but I just wanted
to say that you're astute observations
about the Japanese culture and and the
way you picked up the language and the
unique experience that you had it's
commendable really because I think I
think you you'll understand that of the
ten other thousand people who had a
similar experience to you your your
understanding and appreciation and
comprehension of what you actually
underwent and the Japanese heart and the
Japanese psyche
the Mishima Guney coaching you you it's
really commendable your level of
appreciation to what you underwent I
appreciate I appreciate it was a
complete life changer for me and
fundamentally changed my entire
trajectory and I'm still in touch with
my my host family I had dinner with them
a month ago in Japan wonderful 25 years
later but I don't know if you know that
day after tomorrow I'm actually going to
Japan I did not know that yeah yeah that
went over for for nine days I've got
exciting an appointment to buy a new
power hammer and going to visit with
some steel manufacturers and then do the
regular rounds of Osaka Sakai Kyoto
Fukui Prefecture up to see my teacher
mr. yeah Suki Sakamoto in Nagano and
then back down to to Tokyo so that's
that's just around the corner for me so
just like so jealous there's a nice warm
up I and so you mentioned your teacher
yeah your master I see you your knee is
taken out you have a book kindly or
aggressively tossed at you not sure but
nonetheless is that is the tinder for
getting you to dip your toe in Japanese
communication sure well I like to tender
I like the tender example because it
certainly it certainly ignited quite a
passion in me and certainly ignited that
fuel so what happened was I think wasn't
it the first day I was at the karate
dojo one of the fellow students there
chika hito I think his name was he had a
little scooter and of course a bit of
scooters all over Japan there little
50cc scooters and he was kind enough
since I had an international driver's
license and was licensed to drive it
even though I didn't have much
experience on two wheels he let me
borrow that scooter for a day you know
in between karate the morning and the
evening karate class and I just you know
bravely it's kind of crazy because I
have no sense of direction and it was it
to the days of GPS but I just intrepidly
took that scooter and started driving
around and I was probably into the third
or fourth hour of my adventure wondering
if I was ever going to make it back to
the karate dojo that I drove past a very
intriguing and interesting building and
I only colored the corner of my eye
because I was probably driving too fast
and it inspired me to put on the brakes
and kind of think what did I just see
and then I know check both ways and did
a u-turn and drove back to this building
and it was kind of like a it's kind of
like a moon it was kind of like a gate
an archway where there was an entrance a
driveway entrance into an inner
courtyard and beside the gate was a
display window with this huge it's what
they call a cookie table which also it's
like a huge whale meat still earning
knife and that was a display piece
because of its monstrosity because
because of its size and so it was pretty
clear to me that mmm there must be some
knives beyond this gate so high I kind
of curiously went inside the courtyard
and part of the little scooter and and
then there was these glass doors into a
building and I kind of peered through
the glass doors and I can see more
knives on display shelves and so I think
I probably knocked and then I and I it
was one of those squeaky you know those
squeaky doors on the rollers the slasher
floors yeah of course they're all
squeaky because they say that the the
squeaky hinge gets the grease but that's
not true in Japan it's just leaking
squeaky so I so I ventured in and I just
kind of became a just mesmerized by all
these wonderful blades and three
directions there was this noise
everywhere in two or three shelves all
the way up to the ceiling there was a
sushi knives and there was devil bull
chills for you know for breaking a card
to fish and there was thin fill it in
knives when there was vegetable knives
and was paring knives and then there was
all sorts of agricultural tools there
was comma sickles and there was
axes and there was a different catch
it's and and different types of hoes for
like digging up that the yama email and
and you know all sorts of fascinating
things to of i've never even seen before
i couldn't even identify and kind of i
was always there looking at all these
blades and i don't even know how much
time passed by i'm guessing it was
probably only a few minutes but i mean
it could have been hours i was so lost
in thought and just kind of just trying
to absorb everything i was experiencing
a man came in from the other side of the
building and he looked at me and he saw
i was a gaijin and he said huddle and
and i guess we talked for a few minutes
and i tried to communicate because at
this point you see i hadn't had the
textbook tossed to me yet this came
before that this being this was before I
injured my knee it was literally the
second as in kumamoto and and we talked
for a few minutes and his wife brought
out a couple of glasses of cold boogie
cha with us my favorite thing in the
world oh you like look at ha ha ha ha
I'm not too fond of Mozilla almost huge
fan yeah but ok this is on the summer
dark wheat buckwheat tea because it was
summer so they started cold and this was
literally this is literally in June
yeah like a late part of June so very
hot and after a few minutes of dialogue
he could speak a word or two of English
and I think I asked hey can I come back
sometime and I think he said Dozo Dozo
it's a demo Russia he said come back
whenever you want so so that was like
one of my first impressions of Japan and
so weeks and I didn't visit him for many
many weeks and then when the textbook
was tossed to me I think something was
to click because I thought that's the
kind of person that if I could have
deeper conversation with I think it
could be really rewarding and so that
was one of the you know the as I said
before it was that tinder that fueled
this desire and passion to to be a
communicator
of course the irony is
having grown up in Nova Scotia Canada in
the 70s we were all spoon said the
French language as Canada's second
language basically from grade one and I
had developed quite a quite a or gonna
say a complex about the French language
because I never really learned much
because I was the class clown and I was
always standing down the hallway while
all the other kids were in the class
actually learning something so I managed
to get myself kicked out of so many
French classes that I really didn't pick
too much up so when I was headed to
Japan and people said Homer you know you
should you should really try to learn
Japanese when you're over there because
when you come back you could get any job
you want and of course that was in an
era where everyone thought Japan Inc was
going to take over the world and Japan
was a focus of all the movies and of
course die hard was all about the
Nakatomi building and the the decadence
and opulence of these rich Japanese
corporations where they had lifelong
employment and it was really quite an
enigma and the world was fascinated by
Japan and everyone thought that you know
Japanese was going to be thee it was
when everyone had a Sony Walkman right
and they thought that Japanese was going
to be the trade language in the world so
people said you're going to Japan learn
the Japanese language you'll be set for
life and I would agree with them but it
would win in one ear out the other
because I'm mumbling to myself under my
breath like yeah right I can't even
speak a word of French and I've been
exposed to it for 12 years you expect me
to learn Japanese in language with a
different alphabet I didn't come on get
serious so so I really didn't have any
expectations or learning the language
and that turned out to be the blessing
in disguise and so much that I just
thought well if I could just learn one
word today just one word just just how
to say thank you or or to say actually
no thank you I remember when someone
tried to feed me raw fish whoever and I
couldn't say no thank you so I had to
eat it I'm front opened tonight I'm
going to open up that text book and find
out where it says how to politely refuse
raw fish liver so and it was from a fugu
nonetheless
god yeah so yeah Blowfish you got to be
careful with the Blowfish yeah so
because I didn't have any preconceived
notion of what I should or shouldn't be
able to achieve in the language I just
literally took it one word at a time and
took great delight and great pleasure in
the new word that I would learn each day
and so you see you now
flash-forward you have this textbook
when did you go back to visit the knife
shop again or or how or what happened
when you went back it's a great question
of course I ended up spending a lot of
time there so that's a question that
should be able to answer I I'm just
going to I'm just going to make it up
because I can't remember exactly but I
stayed in Japan that first stint for
nine months and first it was with karate
and then I met the Japanese blade Smith
and then I delved in a whole bunch of
different things and then I went back to
to North America and enrolled at
advanced reading and writing Japanese at
the University of British Columbia in
Vancouver Canada I took four years of
study in 12 academic months and then I
went back to Japan and and and that's
when I immediately went to mr. Sakamoto
said I'm back I speak the language now
and I really want to learn about blades
nothing I may or may not have met him a
couple of other times during that first
nine month stint but honestly I don't
remember okay so I want to hit hit pause
to dig into one thing that you just said
because it's fascinating did you just
say you took four years of academic
Coast courseload and in 12 months
yes exactly okay so just a former class
clown is that a superhuman feat did you
just go to class all day every day how
did you go about what were the keys to
getting that done sure sure so so when I
went for an interview with the Dean of
the Japanese Studies program mr. Heos
Olga at the time we would actually also
written most of the textbooks in the day
I immediately took my interview with him
in broken Japanese and I said please
please
please let me take the 200-level classes
both the reading and writing and the
conversation and he said and as I was as
I was trying to have a conversation with
him he was correcting every second work
I said he says you can't talk me grammar
is everything I said come on you
understand what I'm saying he says yes
but but the big difference between I
want to eat and I've eaten and so Pence
is everything so we came up so he was
very gracious and we said listen if you
study through the first year or 100
level textbooks in the next month and
bring the evidence that you've done all
the exercises and and and and pass some
verbal examinations then I'll also let
you enroll immediately in this second
year classes so for them so I
immediately enrolled in 200 level
classes while on the side I was also
completing all the course material for
the 100 level or first year classes so
by the time if I enrolled in September
by the time the end of October came
along in two months I had finished all
of those 100 level class you know
workbooks and passed his his his
expectations and I was getting aids in
my 200-level classes so I took you know
the reading and writing and then the
conversation class from September until
probably April when the University
academic year ends and then I enrolled
in the spring six weeks intensive three
hundred level classes and then when they
finished I took the six-week intensive
400 level classes which was you know
reading Japanese newspapers and you know
conducting business and Japanese and
honorifics and so on so that's how I've
managed to do all four year study in
twelve calendar months so this was
before you really took a deep dive with
the blade smithing so what was driving
that that motivation to do so much and
to really get after it was it the hey
Japan is going to take over the world
was that an element of it was it an
inexplicable having caught some type of
idea virus that you just couldn't kick
related to Japan B was did you know how
you were going to you
I know there's a lot here but what was
driving that studious nasai wasn't that
that isn't how it sounds like your
academic career started so what was
driving that well I want to be cute and
say that Japan had taken over my world
and I wasn't so concerned about it
taking over anybody else's when I when I
went to Japan something very magical
happened you know the the advice or the
adage for four youngsters for decades or
even centuries has been you know go it
on your own and find your own fame and
fortune you know and I certainly hadn't
found Fame nor fortune what I did find
in Japan was a part of me that I never
knew existed
as I mentioned before you know I I had
grown up with a tremendous complex when
it came to languages I had never really
excelled at sports I felt in many ways
that I probably hadn't lived up to my
own father's expectations and as the
only boy because you know I wasn't doing
baseball or soccer and any other things
that all the other boys were interested
in I spent most of my childhood inside
watching TV and playing with Lego and
just wanting to do things with my hands
so when I went to Japan and then found
out I had that this latent skills for
languages and I made all sorts of new
friends and and nobody was judging me
based on what I had accomplished thus
far in my life and it was just all new
fresh relationships I really was in many
ways able to reinvent myself and and it
wasn't as much as I was reinventing
myself as I was discovering parts of
myself that I never knew existed
and I think that for any young person
you know whether it's a musical
instrument or a language or a sports or
really anything that they dedicate
themselves to and gain a certain
proficiency in that that kind of skill
can give a young person so much
confidence and open up so many other
doors for them and really be one of the
greatest stepping
stones from which you know to launch the
rest of your life you know to step out
into life on so as I was learning the
Japanese language and getting
tremendously positive feedback as you
mentioned from Japanese people because
they were just so and this is in the 80s
before you know the foreigners had
really penetrated every corner of Japan
and I was down in Kyushu and I remember
if I saw a foreigner on the street I
would go out guide a guide to dub
because I never thought on that right
now there's a seat you see foreigners
everywhere but back in those late
eighties it wasn't so common so you know
I got tremendously positive feedback
from the people around me I started new
friendships and and they encouraged me
in my language study and and and I think
for the first time in my life I remember
having feelings like wow you know I've
got some skills I could really be
somebody this is great I really want to
see how far I can take this and it gave
me Drive and kind of passion and
dedication that I never do I possessed
before in fact I thought I was kind of a
quitter growing up because I mean that's
whatever all the adult influences around
me said I was a quitter and then I'd
amount to nothing so I was quite
delighted to find out that might not be
true yeah what a great story I I think
I'm like I say the exact same but a very
very parallel experience and I really
shudder to think what my life would be
like had I not had that year abroad
which is very uncommon or I say less
common in the u.s. been many other
places where a gap year is encouraged
and I've thought I don't have kids but I
thought about if I would have any
non-negotiables that I would insist on
if I had kids and the only two that I've
really been able to come up with in
terms of experiences our sports of some
time and could be something that is
thought of as unathletic but let's just
call it sports and then a gap year or a
year of traveling in a foreign
environment because of everything that
you just said I think it's just such an
incredible opportunity to find yourself
and find your own confidence
uh so let's let's I'd love to jump to
now you mentioned honorifics so for
people who don't know what that is there
are many different levels of many
different ways to speak or write or
communicate with another another
japanese person let's say a japanese
person depending on how old they are
depending on where they rank relative to
you even in say a school environment you
would have simple like the upperclassman
above you and then the kohai below you
and so on and it determines what type of
grammar in some cases you use and I was
going to ask you could we I'd love to
hear when you then came back to Yoshi
Yoshi multiple son some people have
heard son before si n and then above
that you would have let's say sama right
and then below that let's say you're
talking to a friend or a younger kid you
might say kun or you could even use Chun
which is kind of similar to that what is
the proper suffix for a master
bladesmith which would you when you
formally refer is there sort of a master
suffix that you would use for mr.
Yoshimoto or is it or is it simply
Yoshimoto song well most commonly we
just use the word sensei since and okay
and you're somewhat the same thing
that's right so so school teacher or
politician or professor at university or
you know master in the forage is Sensei
and for for for people who are language
nerds just because I don't get a chance
to explore this very much on many of my
podcast so since a is a really
interesting word to look at or suffix to
look at literally because you have same
which is before and then say which is
born and in effect it but in Chinese
it's totally different
it's literally it means mister so you
would say like Kali Shan Shan Shan
Hsiung is mister so you don't use it for
say a woman
in the same way that oddly enough like
tegami which is can hand paper means
letter in Japanese but in Chinese or
Mandarin shoulder shoulders toilet paper
so there are a lot of things that are
the same in both and a lot of things
that are very very different so how did
mr. a Yoshimoto sensei how did he react
to the picture for you well first of all
yeah I want to clarify one thing that I
am 17 to generation Yoshimoto bladesmith
but my teacher's name is Sakamoto ah
okay got it
all right so yeah I need to and just for
your just for your listeners pleasure if
they're interested in in the content of
this podcast they can go to youtube and
see the history of the Yoshimoto
bladesmiths by on carter cutleries
channel and you can see how Yoshimoto
became Sakamoto because that in itself
is a very interesting story but got my
teacher's name is that
Sakamoto sensei I got it okay so
Sakamoto sensei within the umbrella or
later than becoming or how that became
Yoshimoto we might delve into that but
so Sakamoto sensei yeah let's could you
tell us more about like when it clicked
what what happened like when did how did
you because ultimately I don't want to
give away the punchline but we're
talking about I want to say see if I get
this part right 18 years in Japan yes
all right very 10 years and so I
apprenticed with mr. Sakamoto for six
years and then basically was asked by
him to take over the family business he
had two daughters and no sons and and no
hold still apprentices apart from myself
and I guess I demonstrated a certain
attitude and aptitude for the you know
for the family trade that he had asked
me to assume the position of 17th
generation Yoshimoto bladesmith he was a
very he is because he's in oh god I'm
going to see him next week he is a very
extraordinary human being
and very untraditional in the way we had
a relationship of apprentice and sensei
and he was not strict as you would
imagine people think of you know the
Karate Kid wax on wax off and standing
there for hours on end doing things that
menial tasks that the apprentice things
thinks must be meaningless and just
being tested and he's just having a
sweet tooth floor you know to do the the
grunt labor for for the teacher and
starting to feel unappreciated and
abused and so on that was not my story
mr. Sakamoto was very gracious and he
would share with me all of his skills
upfront and of course I could only
comprehend so many so I would go and
practice things he showed me and then he
would show me more things but once we
get to a certain point where he felt he
had shared all of the essential
bladesmithing and sharpening techniques
with me that he regularly practiced he
did something out of the ordinary he
said he said Mary you know if you if you
really want to learn about Forge welding
you know I'm going to arrange for you to
go down to college itty and and spend
some time down there because that's
their area of expertise and so I would
go down to collar shitty and in fact I
kind of went off and on down to collar
City for a couple of years and mastered
the technique of Forge welding and then
misters and I would always come back to
second Lotus Forge and use it as my home
base and always apply and put into
practice what I had learned there and
elsewhere at the home Forge and then
you'd say you know you really need to
learn about about the the traditional
Japanese fishmongers knives the katana
the devil Bojo and the sashimi knife and
all those two layers special kind of
chisel ground blades so you should go to
Osaka you know a little special place
called Sakai where they specialize in
that skill and so off I went to to Sakai
for for several weeks and and I would be
hooked up with some very again gracious
bladesmiths there and I would learn
they're trained that come back to
Kumamoto to Sakamoto's shop
and then like the fire and try to
emulate or put in the practice of things
I've learned and I'd show them to them
is okay you know you're now you're
getting somewhere and I think now you
you need to learn a little bit about
marketing and the overall you know
financial aspect of running a business
making knives so you need to go to
second city Japan because those guys are
really savvy businessmen when it comes
to the culinary industry up there so off
I would go to second city Japan and
learn what I could up there and then
again I always come back to mr. second
law and then apply what I had learned so
he he was he taught me many important
things but he also coached me and he was
very gracious coach and never cool or
strict or punitive even when he probably
should have been but very very kind and
the most tolerant and understanding and
patient sensei you could ever have asked
for that's such an amazing opportunity
just incredible what what for people who
are listening and I'll be honest I would
say I'm in this group as well who don't
don't know the steps involved with say
Japanese blade smithing don't even know
what Forge welding is which I will
certainly raise my hand as it relates to
that could you describe what makes
Japanese blade smithing Japanese place
smithing so people people there's I
wrote there's a certainly a sort of
prized
quality that goes along with Japanese
knives I a book related to cooking and
learning some time ago called the 4-hour
chef and I spent a lot of time with with
high-end chefs around the United States
in San Francisco New York City and so
and then they and almost every single
one has at least one Japanese knife that
they treat like a Lamborghini it's only
taken out for special occasions it's
meticulously cared for could you
describe the the steps in making a knife
in the Japanese style and and what is
unique
it sure you know there's there's so much
to to say on that topic I'll just try to
keep it concise and interesting for your
listeners first of all there's kind of a
fundamental kind of philosophical
difference between what I'm just going
to loosely term Western cutlery and
Japanese cutlery and you know everybody
knows from movies like Kill Bill and and
so on just a how revered the samurai
sword can be people even know that often
they were christened with their own
names and you know considered by their
owners to have legendary qualities some
of the big philosophical differences are
that you know Western culture puts a
high value on something being kind of
durable and strong and tough and robust
and as a result is that kind of extends
to color and we end up with a lot of
western blades that are kind of sharp
into tools and they're robust and
they're durable and you can use them for
almost two different things but fine
cutting implements we would not call
them we would call them sharpened tools
by contrast the Japanese blades at least
the best Japanese blades that come from
Japan are considered to be precision
cutting implements and they are designed
and built and forged and quenched and
tempered with cutting performance up
most in mind at the cost of everything
else so because of that philosophical
difference there's a lot of mechanical
differences in how the blades are made
and the mindset of the blade Smith
making them from the materials that are
chosen to forge the blades from the fuel
fuels in the fire that's used to heat
the steel to forge it the manner in
which it is forged the medium in which
it's quenched the dimensions to which
its ground the effort to which it's the
final cutting or primary edge is honed
is all affected or influenced by this
philosophical ideological difference
between what
blades are supposed to be able to do in
the end and could you describe some of
these steps like that for instance I
don't actually really know what forging
is or involves our quenching or
tempering I really don't know what what
that looks like could you describe the
process if from from ground zero when
you're considering making a knife what
does the process look like
sure well I'll try to share with you
what I've learned in having forged and
completed over 24,000 blades in my
career a lot of the things that I've
realized that have come about at certain
times of my of my experience and I'm
sure by the time I've made fifty
thousand of them I might have a slightly
different look altogether but so one of
the primary differences between a
western blade and a Japanese
high-performance blade is the use of
laminates most western blades are
homogeneous in construction meaning
they're either all carbon steel from the
spine all the way down to the cutting
edge of the blade or they're all
stainless steel but throughout they're
the same kind of Steel they're all
manufactured from one solid billet of
homogeneous steel by in contrast the
Japanese blades are almost always a
combination of two or more different
kind of Steel's and so you've heard the
expression have-your-cake-
and-eat-it-too well if you combine a
hard and a soft steel together in the
same package or in the same blade the
hard steel can be really hard and and
and and contribute to superior cutting
performance and the soft steel can be
less soft so that it's super tough shock
absorbing avoiding breakage and also
easy to sharpen it's very difficult to
get the qualities of soft steel and hard
steel out of a homogeneous blade because
it's all the same so right away we're
starting with a different blade
construction and that's that's a
laminate the most common blade
construction in in Japanese cutlery is a
three layer blade construction
and referred to as a sign my which means
three layer or three to chic style
construction where the center of the
laminate is the hard steel that's going
to become the sharpened cutting edge
like the lead in a pencil and the outer
laminates are a softer either mild steel
or a soft stainless and they they
strengthen toughen cushion and make the
blade easy to sharpen and very much act
like the wood on the outside of the lead
inside of the pencil and they support it
that's the most common there's two layer
construction and then there's a sword
construction which is where the hard
steel wraps around a soft Center core
and then you can have Damascus style
construction we've got hundreds of
different layers all in different
different kind of constructs for either
a visual effect or metallurgical effect
but the laminated blade does give you
the best of both worlds it does allow
you to have your cake and eat it too
because you can have a really high
Rockwell a hardness core that means it
can take a razor-sharp edge and hold
that edge for a long time but avoid the
pitfall of being brittle because the
outer software laminates support it and
keep it keep the whole blade from
fracturing right and how does one make
such a knife what is the what is what
are the steps involved yeah so you
achieve a laminated blade through a
process called Forge welding and you
know everyone knows if you hear the word
welding you think of like a big or a tag
or an inner gas welder in a big spark
and bright light but there's literally
you know there's lots of different types
of welding there's alter sound welding
there's welding with explosives welding
through friction and so on but cords
welding is is the oldest form of welding
known to mankind and that's when you
take two metals that have similar
temperature ranges and you heat them up
until the molecules on the sir
of each metal start to liquefy and then
you join the two you press the two
together and if you're at the right
temperature and you have clean surfaces
you can actually get the molecules from
each surface of the metal to intermingle
and fuse together in layman's terms is
like taking two candles that are cold
and hard and you would heat up each end
over a flame source until the the end of
the candle just started to liquefy and
then if you touch the end of both
candles together at the same time in an
ideal situation you would end up with
one big long candle once it cooled down
because the wax would would intermingle
and mix right it's different than
melting or fusing is different than
melting the metals together where you
would basically make the to melt the two
dissimilar metals molten and basically
mix them up in a pot like you would stir
chocolate milk powder into a glass of
chocolate milk it's not that kind of
mixing it's it's fusing them together in
such a way that each unique layer still
maintains its original characteristics
right and so that's done in a forge and
a forge is a source of heat we have gas
forges we have electric forges and then
we have what I use which is a solid fuel
Forge what is solid fuel mean so I burn
up coke in my Forge spoonfuls at a time
and as funny what is coke we talking
Coca Cola cocaine something else yeah
and I just purchased four tons of coke
the other day coke is all joking aside
it's it's cool as they dig it up from
the ground and then it's heated once in
the absence of oxygen and it drives off
all the impurities namely phosphorous
and sulfur which are combustible gases
but that are very undesirable when it
comes to heating steel to make knives so
so coal excuse me
coke is too coal what charcoal is to
wood I see guys just
it's purified carbon because all the
volatile gases have been driven off how
is that spelled okay co ke Otis alright
I was going to say a couple of tons of
cook unless you have a very
sophisticated drug smuggling operation
and a huge budget it's probably
something else yeah so that is solid
fuel that's right that's solid fuel
Forge so you're you're fusing these
different layers together and
maintaining the integrity in the sense
that the separation of these layers so
you can design a knife that allows you
to have your cake and eat it too what
happens after that
so once you've successfully forged
welded your different layers of Steel
together then you need to forge that
billet which is what is called into a
blade shape and some blades are wide and
and short and some are narrow and long
in the case of a slicing knife some are
thicker and some are thinner and you can
set out from your billet to forge really
any kind of blade you desire providing
you've got enough material to make blade
you're setting out to make and it
involves heating the steel to a plastic
state which is usually around 800
degrees Celsius and I talk because I was
in Japan and I was in Canada for me
everything Celsius that I don't that's
right don't translate to Fahrenheit very
well but I think it's something like
1,350 degrees Fahrenheit but it's it's
what Steven look it's what when you're
at a campfire you see the orange coals
down at the very bottom they're not
bright yellow they're just kind of like
a a really bright orange color that's
about 800 degrees Celsius and that's the
color we want this field to be when we
start hammering it
it's very pliable in that state you
don't want to keep the steel hotter than
that because you can literally burn the
steel and ruin it and you you start
hammering it and and if you have enough
force with with a hammer you you can
force it into different you can you can
coax the steel into different shapes
obviously I mean blacksmiths have been
doing that period for millennia the big
difference is is
as a new bladesmith one is overly
focused on getting the right shape
somewhere along the line somewhere
between 15,000 and 20,000 blades I
realized that something more important
was happening when I was forging this
steel and that was grain refinement as
it turns out that if you heat your steel
your your laminate your billet of steel
to that 800 degrees and then Hammer the
steel as it's cooling you're actually
refining the grain in this steel which
we can result in a higher performing
blade so even if you start out do you
make two different blades even under the
same steel how you heat the steel and
how you hammer it and how sequentially
you heat this deal will will result in
two entirely different quality of blades
and when you say grain I'm thinking of
cutting against the grain or with the
grain and say cutting steak is is it a
direction of fibers in the steel itself
or how what's the best way to think of
refining grain yeah so if you've ever
fractured a piece of metal and looked at
it is quite likely even if it was
alumina whatever you look at the the
metal fracture surface and it looks like
little grains of sand it looks granular
and sometimes it looks very very like
five finely granular and you have to
look very closely to discern like
different bumps in the fractured surface
and sometimes it's very coarse and
basically steel has grain which you can
think of like marbles or bb's or grains
of sand and the finer they are and more
evenly dispersed they are throughout the
steel matrix or through it the billet
the finer of a cutting implant that will
result got it the reason is is
it's not the grains themselves that make
feel strong but the grain boundaries so
where one grain touches another grain
there's something about that boundary a
complexity that that increases the
strength of steel so the finer grain you
can achieve and steel the more grain
boundary that results and therefore a
better end product now you have as you
said forged or produced somewhere along
the lines of twenty four thousand blades
and you spent 18 years in Japan and yet
this is this is another part of your
story or life that really grabbed my
attention you hold classes or workshops
where people can come in and over the
course of a week or a few days walk away
with a blade that that is that it's fair
to say oh yeah I've been doing that for
five or six years now so after putting
in the amount of time to master your
craft that you've put in what does the
curriculum look like for say a two or
three day class because you've clearly
put so much thought into this how do you
how do you teach this like what and I
always think about sequencing right when
you're learning a language how you
provide positive feedback but balance
that with some kind of logical
progression that is that is a graspable
i what is what does such a class look
like when you're when you're teaching it
sure sure fair enough because the way
we've talked about twenty four thousand
blades in eighteen years it sounds
daunting and impossible to learn
anything important in such a short
timeframe is one week but fortunately
that's not true
blade smithing is not rocket science and
a lot of the mystique and lore of blade
smithing is simply because a lot of the
obvious things about blades are our
hidden in plain sight and not often
revealed and not often taught know what
I mean by that may quantify that
the main skill that I teach or confer in
a short amount of time is I teach
students how to use their eyes
and how to see what's actually there and
obviously we were talking earlier about
grain and steel and so on and we don't
actually get out microscopes and look at
that but I teach them to see if blades
are straight I can teach them to see if
the blades have the profiles that
they're looking for as they grind the
blade I teach them to to pinpoint area
trouble areas and then pinpoint the the
remedy for that like with grinders or a
hammer or a file or whatnot
but I teach them and through repetition
teach them to start to rely upon their
eyes and the trustor eyes so that when
they actually see something they know
what they're really looking at and in
terms of the metallurgy after we Forge
and and anneal and quench and temper
blades and then grind them I teach them
simple things like how to test to see if
an edge if the edge of the blade or if
the whole blade actually hardened by
cutting into other metal objects I teach
them to to do a rudimentary test to see
if they've got fine grain and if they
quench at the right temperature and
tempered it properly when if they push a
thin edge against an object like a brass
rod they should be able to see the edge
flex and then when the pressure is
removed they should see that flex
portion spring back to a true edge again
and then last but not least you know
part of what we do is we always we place
a lot of emphasis on hand sharpening of
the knives on sharpening stones and I
teach them to pay attention to how the
blade that they forged he treated how it
feels on the stone when they're
sharpening it so between a sense of
touch and feel and using one's eyesight
it's actually a remarkable testament to
the human condition to report just how
much the average student can learn in
the space of a week it's really
remarkable and if you were looking back
at the students you've taught the people
you've encountered in the process of
teaching and making knives certainly if
you were in charge of talent scouting
let's just treat it as like the Oakland
Athletics Moneyball type of approach
your job is to put together a slightly
different but you're trying to put
together a team of people who have
potential to be great
bladesmiths mm-hmm what are the
attributes that you're looking for to
put together that team like how would
you try to spot the potential for
someone who can be great at this what
are what are the patterns you've noticed
or things you've observed well that's a
very timely question Kim because we're
actually our actives
growing cargo cutlery and as we spent
the last week hiring our tenth employee
so very timely question I look for two
very specific things I look for attitude
and attitude and the aptitude is you
know somebody's ability to acquire new
skills or to use the skills that they
already have and I look for attitude
which is a willingness to learn a
willingness to to to to be humble a
willingness to just stick to something
once you've decided that that's what
you're going to do so stick-to-itiveness
and a willingness to to work in a team
environment so those two qualities is
specifically or what I'm looking for so
on the I suppose the aptitude side of
things the ability to learn the ability
to be humble the ability to stick so the
stick-to-itiveness and the teamwork how
do you test for that in other words how
do you determine if someone has that or
not attitude the attitude
yes exactly any of those things in other
words if you're looking at it as a
hiring process to some people who use
interviews some people use test projects
for hiring for many different skills how
do you determine if someone has the
capacity to learn the ability to be
humble stick to something and work in a
team
unfortunately I I found that the only
accurate way to make that assessment is
to put the candidate in the actual work
environment because two things can
happen people who claim to have great
aptitude and attitude will reveal that
they actually aren't that equipped for
for that position
and conversely people who think they
might be once they get into the
environment and it encouraged in their
right way and surrounded by the right
kind of people then with the right you
can actually develop a healthier mindset
that they then they eat better than they
even came into the interview with that
that can be nurtured so I think the the
best solution is to get the applicant in
the the working environment and then
just work with them as closely as
possible and encourage them in every way
you can and be in constant you know
communication with them and I think
usually within a week or two you have a
much better idea than just simply an
interview or or viewing a portfolio or
reading a resume alone can provide for
sure young and for those people
listening who would like to explore this
aspect of business meaning hiring or
even more specifically auditioning
people Matt Mullenweg has been on the
podcast CEO of automatic thought of as a
lead developer wordpress has a very very
fascinating process for auditioning
people whether they are the entry level
customer support or a CFO the process is
remarkably similar so that's worth
digging into I have a couple of
questions that are really not organized
by any particular team I'm just curious
to know the answer so the first is in
many knives that are supposedly
japanese-style
that you can buy easily in the West you
find these dimples on the sides of the
knives and sometimes are called santoku
sometimes they're called something else
what is the function of what are the
functions of those dimples do they
matter are they done well how should how
should someone think about those if they
really have no familiarity with knives
okay well I think what you might be
referring to are kind of like hammered
texture into the upper surface of the
blade and sometimes what you might be
referring to is I think is what's called
a great
where the steel is actually scalloped
out that's right yeah so it looks like a
I think it's concave I think I'm getting
this right
say ellipse or a semicircular carve out
and yeah cross ankles Henkels is well
known for that they put out a kind of a
japanese-style santoku shaped blade that
has a great edge where right behind the
primary cutting edge of the blade are
these scalloped out depressions right
that's right yes and the concept is is
that when you're cutting something has a
high moisture content like cucumbers or
tomatoes or whatnot that rather than
sticking to the blade and then being
pushed up by subsequent slices to the
top of the spine of the blade and then
being popped off the blade and rolling
off the table and onto the floor the
idea is that you're cutting the cut
material will separate more easily from
the from the secondary edge of the blade
in concept it's it it can work I don't
like it for several reasons first of all
if you have a blade that is thick enough
behind the cutting edge to grind in
scalloped indentations for me that means
the blades simply too thick right
because the thicker of the blade the
more resistance it is to to push the
blade through things many people need to
understand that when we think of the
word sharp and blade there's actually
two phenomena there's the primary edge
which is the part of the blade everyone
thinks of only think of sharp that
initiates the cut it's the part that you
know goes into your finger first before
you see the blood and and then there's
the secondary edge which is the geometry
of Steel behind the primary edge and the
secondary edge is what becomes
consequential when you're actually
trying to push the blade through things
whether it's an acorn squash or a big
thick rubber stall Matt you know like
that you might be standing on your shop
to say wear and tear in your feet if
you're trying it or or or a six shoe
leather if you try to push a blade
through things and what's going on in
the secondary
is absolutely important as much if not
more important than the sharpness of the
primary edge and in cooking we often
need to push the blade all the way
through things whether it's cucumber
carrot apple potato whatnot so the
center of the blade the better so if
you've got a blade that's got great on
edges on it your blades simply too thick
and one of the first things we do to
remedy that when blades like that come
into our shop for sharpening
refurbishment or repair is we grind the
blade down you know by a certain
percentage and remove some of those
great on edges but it the resulting the
thinness of the blade greatly enhances
the cutting performance the other thing
I don't like about those is they they're
not necessarily sanitary you know that's
that's an area where bacteria and food
particles can hide out in and in an
ideal world a blade for culinary use is
very clean on both the primary and
secondary of services so once you're
finished using it you simply put it in a
cloth and with one swipe you can get the
blade completely clean so it's very low
effort to keep it clean and sanitary
makes perfect sense uh okay so having
spent so much time in Japan I would love
to know if you have any favorite any
Japanese sayings or mantras or anything
that have really stuck with you and I'll
give people just a few examples of
Proverbs for instance like coca wasa
so there there's some great ones in
English as well of course but you have
like Sodom oak econo cheater right so
even a monkey falls from a tree which
means it doesn't really matter how how
good you get you can still fall on your
face in effect there other uses also but
then you have something that is actually
pretty similar to a tall poppy syndrome
in say New Zealand and Australia where
people who stick out too much can be
pulled down and that's dead Oakley well
who's not a tree right so the the stake
that sticks up gets hammered down so if
you stand up you could be criticized one
that is great that I really like also is
cheat on ooga Hoboken so the knot not
knowing is Buda literally but it's
ignorance is bliss basically or what you
what you don't know can't hurt you is
there anything there any sayings in
Japanese are principles that have really
stuck with you
you know Jim you and I are really two
birds of a feather we share so many
similarities and and Koda Wazza was one
of my areas of I was kind of considered
a nerd during Japanese language study at
University of British Columbia because I
loved coming in with new catalyzes to
share with everybody but one of my
favorites is yoga Bob Holliday okay
teaching that meaning that when you feel
yourself in a great hurry and a kind of
a panic to get things done that's the
time to take a moment and regroup and
take a deep breath and to really get
your footing and make sure that you're
making good decisions so I really like
that one I like EC Basile too tight a
Wataru being very proceeding so
cautiously as to tap with a stick every
single stone in the stone bridge as you
cross it just to make sure the stone
bridge isn't going to fall down while
you're on it so it's a it's used often
to to illustrate an extreme level of
caution and prudence and you apply that
in your life to knife-making
to other things where would you where
does that come to mind for you most
making business decisions I got it okay
right so definitely measure twice cut
once with that thing zactly yeah exists
that would be this would be like measure
10 times right some sometimes it's used
to sarcastically for someone who's so
cautious is that they become petrified
from doing anything you know yes I also
like a lot is
I said I will forget it and this is a
special one in the cutlery industry
which is you know don't don't panic
don't be in a rush
I get the job done what was the what was
the first one that you mentioned the
when when you know all about he still
got bought mallet it you still gotta my
lot it that's that's such a good one
yeah when you feel rushed when you feel
like you have to get everything done
this instant that is a great time there
was to hit pause and and lastly
sometimes when we're in the blades shop
and you think you just when you think
you've seen it all and done it all and
and suffered every single setback that
you're there ever could be in the blade
shop sometimes we become key cuts on
which is a different version of your
subtle demo peek at what you do of
meaning that anybody can fall key coach
Stefano is is is when you become kind of
bereft by some kind of unexpected
setback you know such as being run off
on you by your wife or something like
that so when when something that shop
goes awry in such a way is no one ever
saw it coming we can be the key cut up
which stuff out I love it uh well I I
know that we are coming up on time
shortly so I'm not going to ask too many
more questions but that we could talk
for days and days and days I am sure so
maybe we'll do a round two at some point
but maybe we'll actually get to talking
about lace fretting on that well yeah I
think that uh I think that the people
who are with us at this point in this
conversation are already converted and
family they are interested more
interested in eyes now than they were
when they turn this on so I think we've
we've yeah we could we could talk for
four days about many different aspects
of knife making and the shared DNA that
we have to Japan but let me ask just
that just a handful more and and I'll be
I'm already happy with the conversation
nope so I'll use this to round it out
what books have you gifted the most to
other people or reread the most
as a child I was fascinated with a book
Ivanhoe and I love this the the story of
of knights and and the kind of heroism
and altruism and fighting for a great
cause so I kind of have a romantic
notion of right and wrong and good and
evil but in terms of the book I've given
away the most of course that would be
blade smithing with Murray Carter of
course the book that I first authored it
was the first of three books that I've
authored and it's a great instructional
book on bladesmithing techniques in
general but more specifically the
application of traditional Japanese
blade smithing techniques besides your
own books which I also recommend people
check out for sure any others that
you've gifted to people they come to
mine I was had probably delinquent and
the fact I've not given many books as
presents and my lifetime I should go
ahead thank you for the for the idea now
I know how next year's Christmas
presents figure it out wait all right
well what let's let's look at it
differently when you gift are there any
items that you routinely give to people
and if the answer is knives what is your
go-to gift knife what type of knife
would characterizes it I have a probably
most noteworthy is the fact that I wear
a knife daily usually in the form of a
neck knife it's a kind of knife that we
hang around hang from our neck inverted
upside-down very securely in a
thermoplastic sheet called Kydex and
it's a really handy blade to have it's
it's the alternative to a folding knife
in the pocket and there's no mechanism
to break and it's easy to sharp and easy
to maintain a very strong for its size
and a excellent cutting potential so
I've been carrying neck knives put my
whole careers of blade Smith and I
typically will meet some person who
inspires me in some way they might be a
young child might be the son of a good
friend it might be a housewife
whoo I think we could could could use
some protection while walking in the
park but I had given more knives off of
my own neck that I've used for several
weeks or months or years that I know are
really good high performing and great
cutting knives i gifted a lot of those
away that's a great answer I love ya
neck nut this is this is also something
that I've been somewhat obsessed with in
the last few weeks so that's that's a to
be continued
so what are you going to come and take a
class ah you know what when we when we
hit stop on this recording I want to
talk to you about that because it's
something I would like to do ASAP
ideally before the time that this
episode comes out at least kid hit
reservation in and the last two
questions this one is if if you had a
gigantic billboard and this is more of a
metaphorical question but you could put
a short message on that billboard to get
it out of millions of people that is not
non-commercial what would that or what
might that message be well I'm asking
for something cliche on there like don't
give up I could but stick to the plan I
had written on my walls over in my
Japanese shop stick to the plan and the
other one under that was concentrate on
the task at hand and it's so easy to get
distracted you know from you stimuli
that focusing and concentrating on the
task at hand
it is often even though it's a simple
concept it's difficult to to execute so
those are some those are some kind of
like truisms or sayings that I live by
what is stick to the plan mean to you
most often why is that one of the two
that you chose well in quiet moments we
already sit down either alone or with
loved ones or people we trust and we we
we see we plant humans plan they say
first
maybe we these through things I probably
need to happen we should do this first
and then this second and then lastly
we'll achieve this and it is so common
in life people sabotage their own plans
they get to a certain part of the plan
and it becomes
monotonous or tedious or difficult or
challenging and all the sudden instead
of sticking with the plan and seeing it
through to completion they think oh what
I need is a new plan right and so you
have people who who habitually
chronically are in the process of making
new plans and never actually execute a
single one of their existing plans is
that something that you've struggled
with or is that sounds like you have
that pretty well handled
I'm wondering is it more a reminder for
your employees or what what is how have
you used that reminder in your life or
for other people ah you're right
I am I've been lucky to have stuck to
most of my plans and achieved the goals
I set out for myself because I've
constantly reminded thought lamb a good
answer
very good answer all right uh give any
parting and I'm going to also ask you
but before I wrap up of course where
people can find out more about you and
so on and I'll put those links in the
show notes for everyone but any parting
comments or requests thoughts for the
people who are listening to this I'd
like to thank everybody for for for
listening and of course I can find out
more about our knives at Carter cutlery
comm CA RT er CU t LPR why.com
and you know we do strive to make the
finest knives in the world high
performance blades that are also very
easy to maintain and we've encouraged
we've successfully encouraged and
mentored tens of thousands of people to
to learn the very easily attainable
skill of sharpening knives and we're cut
we've kind of revitalized that essential
skill and given great people given a lot
of people the great feeling of a mastery
and satisfaction over their cutlery and
being able to maintain it and sharpen it
and and use it to their heart's content
could you give just with that teaser
could you
could you name one thing you wish more
people did related to knife sharpening
or one thing you wish people would stop
doing I'll give a little freebie out
there for everybody and that is that
when they get a new piece of cutlery
especially one for the kitchen if they
will just keep that cutting edge from
touching anything other than food
meaning don't drop it in your kitchen
sink don't let it touch other plates and
pans don't let it touch the other
silverware in the drawer
and that will preserve the cutting edge
the primary edge of that knife far
longer than they ever thought possible
it's declining around of the knives the
the miss placement of the knives in the
kitchen that really dull them so that's
a little freebie for everybody so they
shouldn't use their kitchen knives for
opening boxes from Amazon in other words
dick they can do that after they master
sharpening that's what they use our
knife for because they so it's only a
couple of minutes until they can refresh
the primary and secondary edges of their
knives
all right well Murray freedom that's the
real freedom that is the free I'm going
so when you can when you can maintain
and master your own tools and everybody
listening you can also find Carter
cutlery on Facebook facebook.com forward
slash Carter cutlery Instagram fantastic
Instagram Instagram also Carter cutlery
and I will put all links to everything
we've discussed in the show notes as
usual so everybody listening can find
all of that as well as more resources
and so on at Tim blog forward slash
podcast for this episode in every other
episode and Carter asked Carter I always
want to call you Carter I have a good
friend named Carter Murray thank you so
much for taking the time there's an
expression in Japanese which I'm sure
you've heard before which is scishow
they say go so when you do something you
never want to do it again at scishow
they say go I have the exact opposite
feeling with this conversation I hope we
have many many more so thank you for
taking the time out the back Guddi
exactly how do you want that back
getting enough so and and as my some of
my Japanese friends said to me with this
bewildered face
in high school they were saying boy oh
my new hongting die oh so I have that
feeling with you that you're secretly
part Japanese which I mean is the
highest compliment so to be continued
and thank you again and to everybody
listening as always thank you and
continue the experiments be nice and be
safe
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email for me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday is that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoyed this
podcast is brought to you by 4 Sigma
tech I reached out to these Finnish
folks young entrepreneurs very talented
after a Acrobat introduced me to one of
their products which is mushroom coffee
this specific one includes chaga and
lion's mane and nuts my socks off I
highly recommend if you try it you start
with half a packet it's very strong and
lights you up like a Christmas tree in
the best way possible people are always
asking me what I use for cognitive
enhancement and for right now this is
the answer I try to force this on all of
my houseguests it is a hell of a thing
but I have employees or people come over
who are working on projects with me I
always try to feed it to them because
I'm going to get the limitless
I think it's a lot we're out of them the
first time I mentioned this product and
for sig Matic on the podcast your
products sold out in less than a week so
you may want to check them out soon if
you're listening to this and the coffee
tastes like coffee
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water and oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you would get in a
regular cup of coffee I don't get any
jitters as free flux or any stomach burn
any of that it's very unusual and very
very cool so if you don't like caffeine
they also offer very strong but
happening free mushroom lectures which I
will sometimes have in the evening I
find chaga specifically to be very very
grounding and earthy so that is another
option and I have a cupboard full of
their products at the moment which is
right around the corner in my kitchen
you can try something you can try a
sample pack which is great also right
now by going to four sig Matic calm
forward slash Tim that's four sig Matic
fo you are SI g ma TI c calm forward
slash Tim and use the code Tim TI m to
get 20% off of your first order and
they're not that expensive anyway if you
are in the experimental mindset I do not
think you'll be disappointed so try mo
this episode is brought to you by
headspace the world's most popular
meditation app I have it on my phone I
use it all the time when I'm in ubers
when I'm in airplanes when I'm in those
in-between spaces and I want to do some
good for myself across all of the guests
that I've had on this podcast
more than 80% have the common behavior
the common habit of some type of
meditative practice it does not have to
be complicated or expensive headspace is
meditation made simple I've used it for
hundreds of sessions myself it provides
guided meditations that you can use
whenever you want wherever you want
whether on your phone computer or tablet
they have sessions that focus on
everything from decreasing stress and
anxiety to eating healthier sleeping
better and even being more creative but
I suggest you keep it simple simple
simple this is a huge impact in my life
try there take ten program it is
fantastic ten minutes of guided
meditation today for
it costs you nothing try it out and I
promise and I don't do this very much
that you will see a significant benefit
from it
download the headspace app and train
your mind for a happier healthier life
learn more headspace calm for / Tim Ted
space.com forward slash Tim
[Applause]